When I came home in 1955 from university
at the time of Martin Luther King,
a lot of people came home at that time
and started having arguments with their parents and grandparents.
My father was born in 1885,
and he was mildly racially biased.
As an Irishman, he hated the English so much
he didn't have much emotion for anyone else.
(Laughter)
But he did have a sense that black people were inferior.
And when we said to our parents and grandparents,
"How would you feel if tomorrow morning you woke up black?"
they said that is the dumbest thing you've ever said.
Who have you ever known who woke up in the morning --
(Laughter) --
that turned black?
In other words, they were fixed in the concrete
mores and attitudes they had inherited.
They would not take the hypothetical seriously,
and without the hypothetical,
it's very difficult to get moral argument off the ground.
You have to say, imagine you were
in Iran, and imagine that your relatives
all suffered from collateral damage
even though they had done no wrong.
How would you feel about that?
And if someone of the older generation says,
well, our government takes care of us,
and it's up to their government to take care of them,
they're just not willing to take the hypothetical seriously.
Or take an Islamic father whose daughter has been raped,
and he feels he's honor-bound to kill her.
Well, he's treating his mores
as if they were sticks and stones and rocks that he had inherited,
and they're unmovable in any way by logic.
They're just inherited mores.
Today we would say something like,
well, imagine you were knocked unconscious and sodomized.
Would you deserve to be killed?
And he would say, well that's not in the Koran.
That's not one of the principles I've got.
Well you, today, universalize your principles.
You state them as abstractions and you use logic on them.
If you have a principle such as,
people shouldn't suffer unless they're guilty of something,
then to exclude black people
you've got to make exceptions, don't you?
You have to say, well, blackness of skin,
you couldn't suffer just for that.
It must be that blacks are somehow tainted.
And then we can bring empirical evidence to bear, can't we,
and say, well how can you consider all blacks tainted
when St. Augustine was black and Thomas Sowell is black.
And you can get moral argument off the ground, then,
because you're not treating moral principles as concrete entities.
You're treating them as universals,
to be rendered consistent by logic.
Now how did all of this arise out of I.Q. tests?
That's what initially got me going on cognitive history.
If you look at the I.Q. test,
you find the gains have been greatest in certain areas.
The similarities subtest of the Wechsler
is about classification,
and we have made enormous gains
on that classification subtest.
There are other parts of the I.Q. test battery
that are about using logic on abstractions.
Some of you may have taken Raven's Progressive Matrices,
and it's all about analogies.
And in 1900, people could do simple analogies.
That is, if you said to them, cats are like wildcats.
What are dogs like?
They would say wolves.
But by 1960, people could attack Raven's
on a much more sophisticated level.
If you said, we've got two squares followed by a triangle,
what follows two circles?
They could say a semicircle.
Just as a triangle is half of a square,
a semicircle is half of a circle.
By 2010, college graduates, if you said
two circles followed by a semicircle,
two sixteens followed by what,
they would say eight, because eight is half of 16.
That is, they had moved so far from the concrete world
that they could even ignore
the appearance of the symbols that were involved in the question.
Now, I should say one thing that's very disheartening.
We haven't made progress on all fronts.
One of the ways in which we would like to deal
with the sophistication of the modern world
is through politics,
and sadly you can have humane moral principles,
you can classify, you can use logic on abstractions,
and if you're ignorant of history and of other countries,
you can't do politics.
We've noticed, in a trend among young Americans,
that they read less history and less literature
and less material about foreign lands,
and they're essentially ahistorical.
They live in the bubble of the present.
They don't know the Korean War from the war in Vietnam.
They don't know who was an ally of America in World War II.
Think how different America would be
if every American knew that this is the fifth time
Western armies have gone to Afghanistan to put its house in order,
and if they had some idea of exactly what had happened
on those four previous occasions.
(Laughter)
And that is, they had barely left,
and there wasn't a trace in the sand.
Or imagine how different things would be
if most Americans knew that we had been lied
into four of our last six wars.
You know, the Spanish didn't sink the battleship Maine,
the Lusitania was not an innocent vessel
but was loaded with munitions,
the North Vietnamese did not attack the Seventh Fleet,
and, of course, Saddam Hussein hated al Qaeda
and had nothing to do with it,
and yet the administration convinced 45 percent of the people
that they were brothers in arms,
when he would hang one from the nearest lamppost.
But I don't want to end on a pessimistic note.
The 20th century has shown enormous cognitive reserves
in ordinary people that we have now realized,
and the aristocracy was convinced
that the average person couldn't make it,
that they could never share their mindset
or their cognitive abilities.
Lord Curzon once said
he saw people bathing in the North Sea,
and he said, "Why did no one tell me
what white bodies the lower orders have?"
As if they were a reptile.
Well, Dickens was right and he was wrong. [Correction: Rudyard Kipling]
[Kipling] said, "The colonel's lady and Judy O'Grady
are sisters underneath the skin."
(Applause)